herzlich konzern wieder leute was heute
wirklich ein besonderes videos ihr habt
dem titel gesehen mein letztes hilf mir
video und genau das wird es sein ich
werde heute zum letzten mal war eine
hilfe machen ja einige wenige von euch
denken sie jetzt vielleicht soja und mit
juckt aber die meisten oder viele von
euch werden sich denken das ist dein
herz wirklich ich habe wirklich lange
lange zeit hilf mir videos gemacht und
oftmals wurde main kanal einfach auch
mit hilf mir assoziiert leute aber ich
habe heute drüber nachgedacht und mein
bauch hat mir einfach gesagt machen kann
machen kann wir können auf jeden fall
mit sicherheit sagen heute dass wir mit
hilfe wir eine ganze menge spaß hatten
wir haben viel gelacht werden viele
teams wir haben viele innerlich geweint
werden viele viele viele gegnern zahlen
verloren vor allem an allererster stelle
das aber wir müssen auch ganz ehrlich
sein hilft mir ist eigentlich nicht mehr
das was das firma war die folgen sich
ein bisschen verändert und es ist auch
ganz normal dass man über die jahre bis
ein interesse an der sache verliert man
kann glaube ich auch allgemein sagen
dass leute bisschen interesse an hilfe
verloren haben das sieht man an den
aufruf zeiten von hilfe und ich in
meinem inneren spüre dass auch und
deswegen habe ich mir heute noch mal
eine klassiker folge rausgesucht es ist
die folge
no money no hanni meine freundin will
nur mein geld und ja das war jetzt
langes intro lasst uns einfach die reise
starten das ist jetzt so als würde man
eine ganze weile an dem gewissen ort
gewohnt haben und man zieht dann aus
irgendwann winken wir hilf mir adieu
sagen welches und machen das ganze mit
dieser letzten feuerwehrleute
naja ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen so wie ich okay leute das hier
ist das internet ist wirklich erfassen
was ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
präsentiert zufolge ist aber kurz ist
antwort ich stelle mir die leute hier
vor wir haben wir hier bei uns leben auf
der linke seite beni der auf kosten
seines vaters erlebt also der scheinbar
nicht selbst aber umgeht und auf der
rechten seite haben wir es ja es ist
bernies freundin und ja es ist eine
goldbarren leute darum auch die folge
normale johanni hey du bist schön genug
gebrauchs den ganzen schmarrn sie
tatsächlich haben wir von dir begeistert
sein
nutzen wir diese kleine pause noch mal
leute bevor es in der folge richtig
losgeht und noch mal über eine sache zu
sprechen
natürlich werde ich auch in zukunft
weiter reactions machen aber eben auf
andere sachen weil wie gesagt die die
welt und die dinge verändern sich in
dementsprechend ist fühlt sich bis heute
aber der zeitpunkt gekommen um hilf mit
jetzt zu sagen es ist recht sollte dazu
noch wobei kurze frage hat sie gerade
eben am anfang den typen nach seiner
meinung gefragt wie ihr das parfum für
den leiter gesagt hat du für dich zu süß
hat sie gesagt ist er gar keine ahnung
hat war seine frau frage ihn dann
überhaupt an erster stelle so erfreulich
da da da hat die verkäuferin wirklich
eine geniale strategie angewandt sagt zu
ihm junge wie heißt ja nochmal benny
benny bist du behindert hast du nicht
gecheckt dass deine freundin eine frau
ist und also ich wusste es wirklich bis
dato nicht ich dachte hier auf youtube
zusammen ich dachte er schwul
das hat er ja so überrascht an da muss
das jetzt kaufen wie viel kostet die
flasche
[Gelächter]
wie die verkörpere so selbst war der
preis überreicht das hätte es vorher
nicht gewusst hätten würden jetzt meinen
dass sie sie die leiden voll komplett
gefliest hat dort überhaupt nicht wusste
welche preis am ende sagt weil t2 kein
mensch weiß was machen die betonung auf
jeden fall geil
nur 59 euro ich kann sich fast dass ich
es gerade selbst gesagt habe das ist
wirklich das ist wirklich willkommen in
der welt von drei milliliter bisschen
orange vanille ich habe keine ahnung
moschus irgendwas 1000 euro und ich
garantiere euch eine douglas verkäuferin
die so aussieht wie diese frau
garantiert für 59 euro könnte sechs mal
ins kino gehen oder ein paar schöne
abende zusammen haben
was brauchst du nicht das ist
schwachsinn wenn die ist echt mal so
wenn ihr okay kurzer reality check
redner über seine rolle in dieser
beziehung ich bin eine frau okay ich
weiß dass es bisher nicht wusste aber
ich bin eine frau
du bist ein mann das heißt wir leben im
jahr 2020 wie sieht heutzutage das
verhältnis zwischen mann und frau in der
beziehung aus leute richtig der mann
muss alles bezahlen ist einfach so ein
kurzer weg dazwischen leute diese art
von frau kotzt mich so geisteskrank an
das geht bis ich überhaupt nicht er
würde ich bin ich so alles drauf und ich
habe auch schon welche von dem typ
kennengelernt
diese lässt ja nein nein komplett
falsche entscheidung ersten sticker du
hast dich von der douglas verkäuferin
balaban lassen ist immer eine ganz
schlechte idee
26 was du machst du wirst wirklich
ausgenommen wie eine weihnachtsgans
jak sda
es ist wirklich so dumm ich bin so froh
dass das jetzt die letzte folge ich kann
es gar nicht realisieren
ich werde euch vor ich dieses video
glaube ich aufgenommen wenn ich fertig
bin damit ich kann es und ist ja es ist
das video
nie wird nie wieder hilft mir nie wieder
diesen trotz rhein ziehen müssen
ich möchte dass vielleicht noch was
anderes zum länger ach so jetzt sind sie
bei seinem vater zuerst haben sie
vielleicht flüssiges gold möglicherweise
einen exotischen champagner aus dem
jahre 1763
nein was heute für geisteskranke penner
an der stelle hat jetzt gelogen heute
wissen wir alle was ich eigentlich sagen
wollte ist ja also schule habe ich jetzt
gemacht das heißt jeweils man
pflichtprogramm erledigt mein ziel ist
es jetzt im leben einfach nur nichts zu
machen einen reichen typen zu finden und
den dann auszunehmen wie die
sprichwörtliche weihnachtsgans deswegen
bin ich auch mit ihrem sohn gerade
zusammen ja das ist alles ein training
das hat alles sind eine stunde später
der abend hat gerade erst angefangen und
benny ist jetzt schon fast pleite 20
euro für das taxi zur bar gezahlt 15
euro für seinen eintritt
warum geht man auch fahren oder pleite
ist also ich meine ich kann verstehen
dass man auch wenn man bleibt ist lust
hat feiern zu gehen
aber wenn du pleite bist du hast so eine
gültige oder an der alle hand ja das
geht überhaupt nicht
und ich bin so happy dass ich wollte
ganz ehrlich so war also ja mir liegt
liegt es mir irgendwie ein bisschen an
herzen auf eine seltsame art und weise
ja ja ist so muss ich sagen habe bin ich
aber froh in zukunft mal allen
gehirnzellen schon zu können ja genau
wegen zum müll
welcher mensch geht durch den club ja
und dann kommt der eigenen song an und
er schüttelt sein getränk einfach so
geisteskrank das im kompletten club
verdunstung von dem tempel finger sind
nur hilfe
und genau das ist ganz einfach nicola
würde meine fünf euro den hörer
erreichen sein
so dumm von ihm heute der erste penny
was sich lehrer denken zweiter deine
funktion als man in einer beziehung ist
es wirklich dicker ich sag's erstmal du
musst du einmal checken
seine funktion als man ist dass du
ausgenommen wird wie eine weihnachtsgans
ok sechs einfach mal was ist dein tag
heute
da wäre es wirklich sauer ich glaube
wenn ihr wenn ja noch nicht kapiert dass
seine freundin eine frau ist er hat es
einfach immer noch nicht verstanden dass
er aus dem gefängnis freikommen card
also ein junges mädchen legt zur
absichtlichen brand in so einer riesigen
immobilie komplett das haus zerstört
millionenschaden kriminalpolizei kommt
zum tatort erwischt sie da und sagt so
sie waren das hirn diese ja aber ich bin
eine frau
ah ja perfekt leute das gehört wirklich
so also eine komplettierung der gold
digger package dazu natürlich auch noch
fremdgehen ist wirklich die meisten
leute verstehen noch nicht wie im jahr
2020 beziehungen funktionieren aber sie
funktionieren genauso ja ausnehmen
pleite machen fremdgehen zu geben sie
ist mir zu sagen mach dich mal andersrum
er ist teil besitzt außerdem die hand
und er hat nur eine wahl so der diesmal
nicht so oft völlig haben so viel dass
jetzt das ist die vollendung und sollte
sind wir nicht alle ganz ehrlich sind
wir nicht alle ein bisschen froh dass
diese stumpf halten jetzt vorbei sind es
werden andere stumpfen kommen ja aber
nicht mehr diese stumpfheit es werden
stumpf halten kommen wie die strengsten
eltern der welt oder andere sachen die
wir in zukunft anschauen werden aber das
hier nicht mehr
und ja so spontan geht es dann auch
wieder zu ende schreibt mir eure ideen
zu diesem video unten an die kommentare
rein was ihr hier bei empfunden habt das
war meine letzte hilfe voll gekriegt
hier einfach nicht vorgestellt dass bio
und hält ihm ein kanal bin ich bin da
schnell raus ich bin frei